qui suis-je vraiment un youtuber faisant
ça par passion ou un escroc faisant ça
uniquement pour l'argent n'étant pas du
tout pareil dans la vraie vie que dans
cette vidéo on va très vite le savoir
parce qu'aujourd'hui on fait un test
scientifique et ouais bon pote j'ai bien
dit mon scientifique sur cette chaîne
youtube
j'ai pensé que ça arriverait un jour à
nos lecteurs disent que le test de ces
sixtine place dans le chase
c'est un sport assez forte
bon après notre série aujourd'hui on est
sûr c'est sur ce litige david qui ont
fait des quizz qui sont un peu haut à 2
fait qu'un peu du groupe bull shit on va
pas se mentir mais là c'est un quiz très
très approfondie on va répondre à une
série de questions hyper précise et à la
fin on va nous dire quelle est ma
personnalité apparent le tester si exact
qu'il fait un peu peur voilà passé le
test
et ça me fout la pression parce que je
sais que c'est pas une connerie c'est
que c'est un peu scientifique là vous
avez des difficultés à vous présenter à
d'autres personnes franchement ouais
c'est jamais évident je trouve de se
présenter à des inconnus à tanger cei
salut moi c'est lucas je fais des vidéos
sur internet maintenant du coup j'ai pas
du mal c'est très court
non franchement non on va dire je suis
d'accord j'aime pas j'aime pas trop me
présenter à d'autres personnes vous êtes
souvent cyber du nouveau penser que vous
ignorez oublier votre entourage c'est
horrible c'est méga vrai mec tu vois je
fais des phases ont des limites que je
suis en hypnose êtes chez la statue pour
entendre du monde j'entends sa voix
étouffée là oui je m'en bats les
couilles mon gars je suis tellement bien
droit et poncé et du quoi vous essayer
de répondre dès que possible à vos
emails et ne supporte pas d'avoir une
boîte de messagerie mal organisé bombay
cool frères toreros regard si elle est
pas mal organisé le 14 1253 mails non
lus bats les couilles frère si vous avez
des facilités à rester serein et
concentré même lorsque certaines
situations d'un lieu à une certaine
pression
non non
ah ouais ça ça va j'ai pas j'ai pas
d'argumentation affaire c'est vrai tu me
fais confiance
habituellement vous ne lancez pas les
conversations c'est vrai aussi étonnant
que cela puisse paraître je lance
rarement les conversations vous vous
sentez supérieur aux autres sections qui
blessent a comme tout le monde ça dépend
de qui est en face et ça dépend aussi du
sujet tu peux pas être supérieure tout
court à quelqu'un donc une ode nages a
envie de répondre notre peut-être un peu
chez ya pas la réponse ça dépend de qui
en face est quel sujet on parle non moi
je vais mettre un nazi je veux mettre un
point pour combler vous êtes
généralement très motivé et plein
d'énergie
la lave ou créés tout ce que j'aime est
le oui à font pas franchement ça dépend
ça dépend totalement en cause sur ma
vidéo moi je suis très motivé et plein
d'énergie mais avant des fois je suis
vraiment en mode nommé hier donc on doit
assurer dire d'accord alors où on va
sentir ok ok haut à tarare ça gagne un
débat vous importe moins que d'avoir la
certitude que personne les contrarier
pas d'accord mais level max où il ya
chez la pire des [ __ ] mon gars comme je
fais un débat j'ai absolument besoin que
l'issue du débat ce soit soit j'ai tort
soit j'ai raison mais ça ne peut pas se
terminer par personne n'est contre est
dès que j'ai un débat avec des proches
vous jure c'est de sa part sur en
embrouille pendant dix minutes et à la
fin on sait qui a raison et qui avait
tant est souvent j'ai raison puisque je
me prosper aux autres au travail à
domicile votre environnement de vie est
assez ordonnée ouais un peu d'accord
allez un peu d'accord c'est pas non plus
le gros rangement mais bon cela ne vous
dérange pas d'être le centre de
l'attention
pas d'accord du tout mec j'ai pas du
tout quand je suis avec des gens et ça
se met à parler de moi j'aime pas du
tout par contre est au centre de
l'attention au genre tu fais des blagues
la merde où tu échoues au bowling ou je
sais pas quoi ça je m'en fous un peu
mais mais dès que ça parle de moi
tournoi je porte pas vos itinéraires de
voyage sont généralement planifiée à
l'avance carrément votre humeur peut
changer très rapidement totalement vrai
au passage on enchaîne on enchaîne
au cours d'une discussion la vérité doit
passer avant la susceptibilité de chacun
totalement d'accord
en fait peut-être parce que moi je me
vexe rarement et au comptage aime bien
quand justement quand j'ai tort et quand
j'apprends des choses bah du coup bah du
coup je considère que tout le monde doit
être comme ça et ça c'est un vilain
défaut je me mets nul à devant vous je
me met à poil votre style de travail
s'approche plus de piques d'énergie
aléatoire que d'une approche méthodique
et organisé aussi un peu des deux c'est
un peu des deux le pit d'énergie là on y
est là on est toutes au delà de la
courbe mais il ya quand même petite
approche méthodique et organisé dans le
sens tels échanges étant et de trucs
ensuite agca ensuite rythme mais bon
j'avoue ok c'est plus des piquets je
m'organise pas très bien un livre ou un
jeu vidéo de qualité sont souvent mieux
qu'une soirée mondaine ses oreilles
c'est vrai c'est vrai être capable de
développer un plan de s'y tenir et la
partie la plus importante de chaque
projet c'est vrai mais je le respecte
pas mais je suis d'accord mais je le
respecte pas nous étions perdus devons
penser lorsque vous marchez dans la
nature mais son bon sens des gens 100 %
des gens mais quand tu marches d'un
point a à un point b tu fais normalement
cheville et tu penses à plein de trucs
tu gagne du temps en fait c'est le truc
auquel tu auras pas à penser quand
justement torah moyen de t'occuper et
pas te faire chier comme tes forces tu
te faire chier quand tu marches là vous
venez tous quitté la vidéo et c'est
normal personne n'a compris en tant que
parent vous préférez les voir votre
enfant devenir gentil plutôt
qu'intelligents ça c'est compliqué je
trouve pas ce que les gens trop gentil
il se laisse beaucoup marcher dessus en
fait et j'ai pensé que mon enfance à se
marcher dessus faut être gentil mais à
des situations où tu peux ne pas être
gentillet mais moi j'ai tendance à être
trop gentil
enfin plus trop bien non je suis
quelqu'un y a mais sinon je préfère
quand même qu'ils soient gentils
moi je suis un peu d'accord ok vous ne
laissez pas les autres influencer vos
actions c'est faux c'est faux de ouf
au contraire pendant longtemps j'ai
beaucoup trop laisser les autres
influencé mes actions mais parce que je
trouve pas que ce soit une mauvaise
chose au contraire je te dire que tu
apportes de la confiance à des gens et
quand ils te font une remarque ou un
truc bas ils le disent pas pour rien
quoi tu le prends vraiment en compte et
souvent du coup ça influence sur mes
actions c'est vrai vos rêves ont
tendance à se concentrer sur le monde
réel et ces événements mais je fais
jamais de rêve
c'est hyper triste j'ai un grand rêveur
je fais jamais grave je fais des petites
punchline de poésie ouais ouais vas-y
impôt d'accor qui aurait dû vous êtes
plus du genre à improviser naturellement
qu'à tout planifié minutieusement ouais
c'est vrai vous appréciez d'aller à des
soirées déguisées ou participer à des
jeux de rôle ouais c'est vrai vos
émotions vous contrôle plus que vous ne
les contrôle et ouais c'est vrai ça vous
plaît car cette réponse en boucle moi je
suis en vacances du coup là j'ai plus
besoin de parler chez mon coin
tranquille je mets ça te réponse à
chaque fois après avoir lu la question
si vos amis sur vraiment triste approuvé
une situation vous a plu
ces types de leur offrir un soutien
émotionnel que leur suggérer des
solutions aux problèmes annonce h est
horrible en fait quand la situation je
la trouve aberrante j'arrive pas à temps
mais ça va aller je suis plus
mais faire voilà pourquoi tu xian mais
ça et ça aussi on travaille l'équipe il
est plus important d'avoir raison que
notre coopératif je pense que je vais je
vais dire oui il est plus important
d'avoir raison que dé le coopératif
parce qu'en fait quand j'étais plus
jeune j'ai grandi avec ma mère et ma
mère était vraiment qu il ya un débat il
fallait qu'elle ait raison tout le temps
il fallait qu'elle ait raison c'est pour
ça que moi même aujourd'hui qu'il ya un
débat il faut qu'il ya un mec ait raison
ou qui a tort mais par contre il ya
aucun problème avec le fait que je peux
avoir ton art amère elle voulait chialer
avoir tort mais des fois ça devenait
horrible c'est hull ou montré par a plus
b qu'elle avait tort
et non elle voulait pas la tête oui les
gens comme ça un gars qui sont imputés
aux qu'il fermait été invités de se
prendre un [ __ ] de couteau et d ouvrir
comme des huîtres étaient plantés
j'avais planté ma mère attention après
la sandt ride équipe entraînée qui quand
je fais non j'avoue now vers l'ouest par
exemple typique manque un truc va pas je
veux dire c'est parce qu'il ya çà çà çà
et j'ai peine même si je suis
coopérative je prends l'huile quand même
en cas ils tâchent compares to over
route faut que j'arrête faut qu'il faut
que je sorte de mulder vient retire
moelleux de mes souvenirs aux maroons se
blesse vous pensez que les opinions de
tous doivent être respectés
indépendamment du fait qu'elle soit
justifiée ou non par des faits j'suis
d'accord peu importe les opinions enfin
bon sauf les opinions très extrême par
exemple nick les juifs on va aller
brûler ça je n'ai pas besoin et envie de
respecter cette opinion hormis les tout
cas extrêmes où je pense que toutes les
opinions doivent être respectées elles
sont justifiées par un vécu en fait
votre énergie multiplier si vous avez
passé du temps avec un groupe totalement
vrai mais tout le monde c'est normal
vous vous souciez trop de ce que pensent
les gens aaa question intéressante pour
youtube heures un peu un peu en fait je
relis ça à la vérité qu'on sait déjà
comment quelqu'un ne m'a jamais parlant
vrai ne m'aime pas ça me fait chier je
me dis mais ne connaît pas comment il
peut ne pas m'aimer
donc du coup je me soucie de ce qu'ils
pensent alors je devrais pas gérer mans
bat royalement les couilles et ouvrir
des huîtres mais non vous avez tendance
à tout remettre à plus tard jusqu'à ce
qu'il ne reste plus à 7 ans pour tout
faire bas comme 100% des humains fait
pas ce genre votre badge en impute un
sac les résultats réputé remet les
questions elles sont géniales
ghoga c'est le meilleur coup on dirait
le un truc de voyants ou tu te reconnais
c'est dans tout ce que le texte disait
sauf que ce que tu sais pas c'est que le
texte il s'applique pour chaque humain
peu importe qui lie ce texte il va
croire qu'il a été fait spécialement
pour lui parce que c'est exactement ce
que le mec ressent ce qui est marqué
dans le texte ben allal en fait c'est un
peu le même délire que je ressens je
veux dire mon dieu monde avec ce quiz
m'était destiné aux allées résultats qui
suis-je vraiment la réponse avocat c'est
quoi avocat l'avocat c'est la bouffe
préféré mais à part ça non mais même
sans gloire bizarre je suis introverti
c'est bon pour youtube heures je suis
introverti
c'est ouf comme quoi qu'ils aient fait
vraiment pas pareil le monde virtuel où
tu parles de joindre à une caméra que le
vrai monde où là les interactions
sociales elles sont vraiment réels quoi
je suis énergie le type de personnalité
et énergie est très rare et constitue
moins de 1% de la population
bref c'est un truc bizarre l'énergie ont
tendance à considérer qu aider les
autres et le but de leur vie mais bien
que l'on puisse trouver les gens qui ont
ce type personnalités en train de mettre
en marche des opérations de sauvetage du
travail bénévole leur vraie passion et
d'aller au coeur du problème pour que
les gens n'aient pas besoin d'être
sauvée du tout aller au coeur du
problème que j'en ai pas besoin d'être
sauvée du tout bas c'est un peu ce que
je fais à traire les vidéos quand dans
le quotidien certaines personnes ne sont
vraiment pas bien et que y
enfin moi et tous les collègues youtuber
et savent où sort un peu d'autres
quotidiens les vidéos ça vous aide à
avancer mais bon c'est comment dire
c'est pas l'intention première de ce que
je fais la boisson première c'est juste
c'est du divertissement au même titre
qu'ahmed faire un film c'est de la merde
et même les énergies partagent en effet
une combinaison de très forts unique
bien qu'il s'exprime d'une voix calme et
posée ils ont des opinions dans les
vidéos vjepa à la voix calme et posée
on est à la bonne voie irritante et
adolescentes horrible ils sont fermées
ou un fort caractère mais il est rare
qu'ils utilisent cette énergie à des
fins personnelles c'est vrai c'est vrai
que c'est pour moi je vais pas trop
vénère ou quoi je m'en bats les couilles
par contre si quelqu'un d'autre ça me
révolte l'égalitarisme le karma sont des
idées très séduisante pour les inf j ai
longtemps dans sa croix non mes mecs
c'est ouf
en fait ce qui me choque le plus dur
face et de l'égalitarisme et le karma
jeu le karma monga ma vie est basée sur
le karma c'est un truc de ouf
il est logique et leurs amis et leurs
collègues en viennent à les considérer
comme des types calme et extrovertie
mais il ferait bien de se souvenir que
les énergies ont besoin de passer du
temps seul pour décompresser récupérer
c'est exactement - mon gars c'est ouf
mais je pense vraiment que ce que je
suis en train de lire enfin dit non à 10
pour le coup et nadal côté là c'est pas
pour avoir des bulles encore avec ma
vidéo sont référencés est ce que là le
truc je suis en train de lire c'est
valable pour énormément de gens d'entre
vous auquel cas c'est un peu technique
de voyante à l'option qui connaît son
caractère et qui tombe et que ces
personnels alors qu'en fait ça marche à
une beaucoup plus grande échelle jusqu'à
raconte oui ce que vraiment les gens
comme ça c'est rare je sais pas j'ai lu
que c'est un quiz très scientifique
qu'il ya seize types de personnalité
possible mais que cette personnalité la
représente moins d'un pour cent la
population j'ai beaucoup de mal à y
croire pour moi contraire ces gens que
c'est vraiment une majorité et je me
trompe complètement cependant il est
vraiment extrêmement important que
l'énergie se souviennent de prendre soin
d'eux mêmes la passion leur conviction
est tout à fait capable de leur faire
dépasser leur point de rupture et si
leur zèle échappe à leur contrôle
ils peuvent se retrouver épuisé en
mauvaise santé et stressé cela devient
particulièrement visible quand les inf j
se retrouvent confrontés à des conflits
a décrit
si cabaye culture merde et ben [ __ ] à
les lobbys pour pass à loutre oh [ __ ]
sur le cul les questions c'était long et
tout j'en pouvais plus obsédé truc hyper
personnel et une semi à pois j'ai
arraché mon pantalon comme les mecs font
des strip-teases je sais pas trop quoi
penser est ce que je me suis fait avoir
par un truc de voyantes et où j'en sais
trop du bullshit monga et en vrai
soixante pour cent des gens alors dit ça
il faut c'est trop loin et trop moi est
ce que je fais partie des gens là
actuellement est ce que je suis le cas
soc qui a pris ce truc personnellement
alors que ça marche pour v'là les gens
comme on l'a lu au début sur la page
d'accueil du site c'est vrai que c'est
effrayant fait tellement c'est précis
fait le gîte mois sur quoi vous êtes
tombé mais j'avoue j'ai la flemme de le
refaire mon gars c'est hyper lourd puis
c'est plus ans il teste est vrai quoi si
vous répondez vraiment bas est ce qui
correspond à vous en fait c'est assez ou
pas écouter ce que vous n'êtes pas trop
fait chier dans ce cas over the run vous
en aurez appris plus sur moi pour ceux
que ça intéresse et pour la majorité qui
s'en bat les couilles je vous baise pas
de test [ __ ] c'est hyper intéressant
je suis sûr que ça va vous intéresser et
que vous avez envie de salutation se
trouve ça déjà tous d'éjecter la vidéo
ne voulais pas le pouce de repartir je
te plains vasif le mendiant je suis pas
de nelson mandela che nelson mendiants
c'est de la merde à la fin de la vidéo
au revoir merci lui
[Musique]